well when I was about 16 17 years old my
cousin had met this girl out of another
city and you know the girl came around
we didn't know she was you know maybe we
did a little vestigation on her check
her out but we can figure out who she
was
well we what we found out in the long
run that she was the type of girl that
came married dudes got into hood and
said guys up well what happened was I
was the one she wanted to set up I guess
wherever she came from
they were speaking my name in values out
there cuz I was putting in a lot of work
I'll shoot a lot of people you know I
mean sticking a lot of people beating up
a lot of people and they wanted my ass
so I guess they got it this girl and
they wanted her to set me up so this is
the way the scenario when I'm in the
hood one day kickin it and one of my
homies tells me man
I get to the hood you know every time we
get to the hood we tell them yeah
there's a 38 in the bush there's a
nine-millimeter in the mailbox you know
we let him know wherever the gun was at
so I get there he tells me there's a 38
inside the bushes okay when he tells me
this it's me my homie a girl in another
unit and my old lady doesn't mean
there's 38 in bushes if you hear this
right there
so we're kicking it wound about 15
minutes past some dudes best buy booming
the way we do is if somebody passes by
and they lookin we let them go if they
make a u-turn and they passed by again
you can you shot it so what happened was
here comes a car who comes by they're
looking they're looking who turns around
in to u-turn boom right through the
street ready gun boom boom oh shoot the
car up must unload the whole ables would
go over so I unloaded all the rounds on
it she had to call me when he had flat
tires everything and left well about 15
minutes later here comes another car
here comes the car this car don't pass
it it stops so I welcome to the car I
look lo and behold it's the girl she's
inside the car now previous to this she
had told her my cousin and he had gone
away for seven years she testified
against so my thing was okay I need to
get rid of this [ __ ] for the simple
fact that she knows too much she's been
around the hood so long that she knows
everybody not by name she knows where
half of us sleep but we lay our heads at
night so my thing is we need to get rid
of this [ __ ]
so what happened was she drove up I
walked up I seen her in the car I went
back rather than 38 put it in my
waistband went back to her car and she
has like 80 to 84 Cutlass you see the
Regal Cutlass I remember it was light
blue so I walk up to the door and I tell
her hey what's up well I'm not knowing
at the same time she's coming to pick me
up she's gonna take me to Pico Rivera to
our main enemies she's gonna set me up
over there there was like 15 20 dudes
waiting for me over there I don't know
this I find this out after what happens
is I get in the car she opens it opens
the door picks up the seat I get in the
back when I get in the backseat someone
else jumps in with me now this guy that
jumps in with me
is my homeboy but I know that he's not
capable of doing what's gonna take place
right now and what's gonna take place
right now he is not capable in other
words he can't hold his water you don't
got enough balls to do what's gonna take
place so I was wearing the back seat I
tell him get the [ __ ] out get out he's
like oh I wanna go with you I wanna go
you I said no get out you said no I'm
gonna go with you no I'm in my head I'm
saying this you can't go you can't
handle what's gonna take place right now
well you don't want to leave the
backseat were argue me in the backseat
find that tom no because there's two
people she's driving there's another
person with her I don't know this person
but this person got to go as well I'm
gang banging I'm in the thick of things
right now I'm heating they're trying
they're hunting me down you know who's
he look at me from other hoods
I'm shooting every weekend at the end oh
she's never weekend at me so I'm
thinking this dude don't have the balls
to go with me so one thing leads to
another
I can't make too much of a commotion in
the back seat she could see me she
listening to us so I showed him the gun
get the [ __ ] out I said all right you
want to go let's go I talk come on let's
go so she starts driving by that time I
take the gun out they say in court
transcripts
I already got convicted and she I need
the gun and I put it to the base of her
skull so here I'm right here put the
guns in the base of her skull now as
we're driving I'm telling her
laughs what the [ __ ] does she turns
right I tell her stop the [ __ ] keeps
going so I haven't shown one listen so
any pistol-whipping at one time oh I
don't break her head but I give her a
pretty good not cuz I hit her with the
butt of the gun boom now she's paying
attention she's listening but at this
time my homie that's sitting next to me
I turned to look at him he's really
nervous really pale and I told him I
[ __ ] told you get out the [ __ ] car
so now in my mind I'm thinking if I do
her and I do her I have to do him
because he is that capable holding his
[ __ ] water so what happens is we're
going we're driving what happens is I
said well I gotta get him in a dark
secluded area so what I do is on the
corner of Telegraph and pioneer
Boulevard there's a bar that they call
the rim ramp now behind the ram ram it's
really really dark there's a couple
dumpsters back there there's an alley so
I'm like okay I'm gonna take it and I
want to put I'm gonna put him over here
and I'm gonna handle him what happens is
she pulls over and back of that place
it's really really dark I get both of
the people out of the car and this isn't
transcripts what it said that I put them
both on their knees execution-style what
happens is what my homie testifies in
court well my homie testify he puts on
paper is that I got him both off the car
I turned around I looked at my homie and
I said I'm a smoke this [ __ ] first this
is what's said in transcripts now once I
said I'm gonna smoke this [ __ ] first
and I turn I want to put the gun back on
the bride as soon as I'm gonna handle my
business my homie jumps on my back now
remember he went with me he's my homeboy
but he got so scared of what's taking
place around you want no part of it then
he jumps on my back when he jumps on my
back we started to struggle the gun
needs my hand and was sliding across the
floor not this moment this woman is
screaming at the top of her lungs for
the police by this time I hear sirens
coming I heard sirens coming so what I
do is I get the gun I cut around the
front and as I'm coming out the front
I see Highway Patrol man sitting at the
gas station he has one of those Explorer
with them the ones that wear the yellow
shirts and go with them and they take
him around and show him you know ropes
and [ __ ] and my thing is he's coming by
that time the cop is siren here's the
commotion the the the the way they call
him the ride-along guy what he does is
he runs around the back of the car and
he's I see him hit the trunk a little
hard to get the Highway Patrol's
attention but at the same time he's
gonna run across the street wall I'm
already by a hand car I got my gun I'm
like you know what on my left is foo
happy you're not gonna catch me I just
did this I know she's gonna tell me
[ __ ] I might as well go out on a bang
so what happens is I put my gun over the
car and I aim now this guy's coming
across a Main Street my thing is once he
crosses halfway that Main Street and he
chased one step off that curb I'm saying
his ass back across the street or lo and
behold I pulled it out that's it Wayne
here he comes
I think what happened was he seen the
shininess of the gun because when he
looked in my direction if you would have
took one more step off that curb I was
thing's ass to kingdom come
but what happened was he stopped he
never took a step off the curb he turned
around and ran back the opposite way so
that gave me time to escape so I'm
running I hear sirens I see the bird
hear the bird coming that's the
helicopter I'm like [ __ ] so I'm running
down an alley I see a set of headlights
and I know the difference between a
cop's headlights and a regular cars
headlights so I see it's a cop well what
I do is I jump over one wall and I was
thinking how can I stash this gun what's
the best way I can stash this gun I'm
thinking I'm thinking I'm looking
there's buckets and all kinds of [ __ ]
I'm like nah they're gonna search right
here well if you decided I see there's a
tree in the backyard and it's pretty big
tree so what I do is I climb up the tree
I break a branch and I hang the gun by
the barrel by the barrels trigger guard
I'm hanging by our trigger guard so in
other words it's by the trigger guard is
swinging on a branch pretty thick branch
so I stuck it up there
I jumped back gallon boom I take off
running again I hear another cop coming
up the island Ford's me what I do is I
get under this motorcycle
now motorcycle has a blue tarp body but
when I went to get under the motorcycle
I end up eating my leg on one of the
pegs that stick out the side where they
put their feet when it right it I hit a
pig and I split my damn leg open so it
is time I'm already out of breath I'm
holding my leg I'm trying to wrap it
with the headband that I had was
bleeding profusely it's breathing a lot
because I cut it on that big little
spike well I don't know what to do so I
go and get a water hose I'm waiting my
legs down waiting my name's young I'll
Center here another car coming up the
alley I know they're cops because they
make a whistling noise with their motor
and when they put the race for some
reason that are always squeaky
the brakes are always squeaking so now
am i what am I gonna do we're gonna go
hominid and get away from this so I wait
I wait I wait
here comes another car as soon as he
passes me I shoot across the street now
I'm running down the street down the
street from a distance I see another
there's so many cops around there's so
many comes from area every first every
second car is a cop here comes another
cop what I do is I die and I get into a
little flower bed it's a little brick
flower bed and I remember I'm laying in
the flower bed I'm trying to catch my
breath
I see the lights cooling over me back
and forth back and forth back and forth
and I'm like oh man I could just imagine
what these cops want to do to me due to
the fact that all these cops know my
name I know the broad gave up my first
name she was married to my cousin so she
knew exactly where I lived she knew my
name what they called me so and I knew
that previously these cops were passing
word around that they wanted to kill me
this was coming out and all I'll share
that they wanted to kill me this was
good detectives for other [ __ ] that was
being done and they were blaming me and
I'm not saying I did it all I didn't do
it all yes I took part in some of it but
I know they want to get he so I'm really
worried about when they catch me what do
I do
my hands up so I picked my shirt up what
do I need to check my shirt off now CCO
I have a gun because I know they're
gonna looking for someone who's armed
and dangerous because the simple fact
that the girl must have told them that I
had a gun
so I go to my homies house I'm hiding
mine in his garage a cop passes another
cop passes they're all shining their
lights I mean with here maybe a 10 or 15
second window I see my girlfriend coming
with her mother and they're going real
slow through the hood I get up to a bush
I wait as soon as they pass I run and I
dive inside the backseat boom soon as I
get the backseat
I tell him oh no go go go so we leave I
end up getting away but what happens is
she knows all my information so they
start raiding all my family's houses
they're making all their houses they're
walking around with a flier that has my
picture on it and says known gang member
says my name what they call me and then
bottom print and says attention known to
be armed and dangerous so they went
around showing these Flyers to all my
homies to my family my grandmother gets
one she shows me the copy and I'm like
whoa he's there looking for me that bad
well I'm not knowing that they're only
stuff all kinds of [ __ ] on me so what
they stuck on me was they get they want
to get me for two murders like four
counts of kidnap and enjoy and I have
Lotus holding looking concealed weapon
and discharging a firearm within an
inhabited dwelling so I had listen
juvenile I got this in the dog down so
I'm on the run I'm on the run for maybe
oh [ __ ] I was on the run for maybe 18
months and I went to Arizona
I went to San Luis Obispo I went to San
Francisco Oakland I went back to Arizona
and it was weird because everywhere I
was at as soon as I felt uncomfortable I
would leave a day or two later they
would hit the house they went all the
way Arizona and find me
it went all the way the Senate was
peaceful to find me and they were right
on my tail I mean the right of my tail
so close that like I said every time I
left one or two days later they would
hit the house and I'd be like oh man
[ __ ] you know I mean there are me so
intently that I'm also finding out
information from the sheriff's station
because we have a few girls that
actually work there as those explorers
and they work inside so they give us
about a vital information about what's
going on when to smooth these girls
rolling out on their getting jobs so
they work inside nervous we're getting
right information you know me hole I
find out that no I sheriff's have their
own Norwich Sheriff's 10-month one I'm
number three number three
the reason I'm number three is because
the two guys in front of me
they've been wanted longer and they have
packed more how could we say more
[ __ ] on top boom they charged more
than they're good with more charges so I
know I'm number three on the sheriff
Seminoles warning I know the person of
flower army armed and dangerous with a
38 - they put the caliber of the gun so
I'm thinking in my head man when he
catch means I gotta kill me when he
catch me to get in kill me well within
these 18 months you could imagine I ran
from him so many times I got so many
times close to getting caught
I always got away I was running him up I
had a gun 24/7 in my waistband I didn't
leave without a gun
now I'm walking around in this thing
shot went in my waist I'm leaning in
some apartments that I already sold up I
had the manager even dealing dope so I
had whole apartments so the I got any
room I want there's empty wounds that
people leave leave all their furniture I
just take over the room on supplying the
manager with dope so I'm like the room
manager so we're living there you know
you know and I'm knowing that eventually
the North sheriff's are gonna find where
I'm at they're gonna just hunt me down
eventually do their job and they're
gonna find me well I'm going to run
and I'm really getting tired of running
I'm getting tired of running for the
simple fact that I cannot lay anywhere
comfortable at night I can't trust
anybody I mean I gotta be careful where
I'm at because if there's a lot of
people there and someone calls the cops
they're gonna come running and make and
I'm gone they're gonna know why I'm
wants to get me and then identify me but
my tattoos had my teardrop on my face
instead of 15mm I'm 17 now I'm gonna be
18 so the guys they're real familiar
with Who I am
what like I said I'm running around
everywhere I'm have any people drive me
here drive me there I went inside the
trunk I let people sit on top of me in
the backseat you know so many different
things because I'm on the run and so
intent me and right now as it stands I'm
fighting I'm willing to fight some life
sentences because there was kidnappers
murders you know and they're just
trapped it's all kind of [ __ ] on me so
what happens is one morning I get up and
it's like a ritual every morning I get
up when I check the traps that I have
what I actually did was I was living in
the corner apartment on the bottom of a
complex and I was in the corner I had
one window I still say on the south side
of the building and another window on
the east side of the building well what
I did was I got bigger pieces of glass I
broke big old beer bottles of glass and
I got the biggest shards and pieces and
what I did was I put him inside the
ground next to my back window what I did
was I set him in different spots and
then every spot I didn't have a piece of
glass sticking out the ground somebody
would step on it and you know I would
hear him because every where there
wasn't a piece of glass I put an
aluminum can so my mind was thinking if
they came to my back window to get me
they see the Newland camps they're gonna
avoid the aluminum can't aluminum can
and step in the area where there's not a
can okay they're gonna step on the glass
when they step on the glass or the nails
that I put in the ground once they step
on that and it penetrates the skin now
they're gonna step everywhere and I'm
gonna hear them step on the cans I'm
gonna know smoothies in the widow and
I'm gonna let them have it
I'm
and who's there no Georgia heroes can't
see me crushed I'm gonna let have
whoever is gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] pump
him full of lead this is my mentality
because in fact I'm on the road for some
serious crimes and you could imagine
what I did from when I was on the run I
didn't care anymore you don't mean I was
going every weekend to everybody's
hurting I would hit him four or five
times in one day four or five times in
one day just hit him four or five times
each of us because the simple fact that
I was the only one out there really
really active in my hood so that morning
I wake up I do my little ritual I check
my traps both sides of my window
everything's cool you mean uh I get
Miguel with my cat my room I got a
couple cameras set up outside I check
you know parking lot
check the driveway you know meaning
everything's cool well thank God luckily
I grabbed my gun I take it to my homies
apartment a few doors down and we
smoking over the dope we get high we're
talking about what we're gonna do today
and I tell me you know what um I'll be
back man I'm gonna go to my house real
quick you know I'll be right back you
know I know he's like all right go ahead
and that's what I gave my gun like
statute under his bed I go to the house
my girlfriend's there I have a newborn
baby maybe about three months old she
has the baby right there and we're
kicking back we're talking all sudden I
hear boom boom boom at the same time I
hear cans start to get crunched so my
first thing is what I ain't got my gun I
think my gun at my homies Alice I combed
out the front door because when I looked
out the peephole there must have been 15
[ __ ] cops lined up ready to come in
the door I have to my people I've seen
just all kind of faces and all kinds of
guns and I'm like oh my god what am I
gonna do I go to the back window to look
out I ain't going away they got a dude's
post up on both sides with [ __ ]
shotguns ready for me to come on the
back window so I'm thinking damn what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do what am I gonna
do it I couldn't do [ __ ] I'm gonna fake
that got my sleep so [ __ ] that I laid
down boom they kick in the door they
charging grab everybody put everybody
for now mind you I'm doing him a fake
name I have no idea I don't care your ID
so I'm giving him a fake name I think I
gave him something like Joe Chavez or
something
they run the name the name come back
clean I can't believe I'm about to tear
away the name came back clean I just
gave him any name any birthday he came
back clean food about 10 minutes later I
see a [ __ ] car pull up and she a
detective get off the car please
detective knows me by face soon as he
comes up he sees me we got him who got
him on they all look give me oh man
there was to beat my ass for like about
five minutes they were kicking me
hitting me with the [ __ ] flashlights
they had one I was [ __ ] foot on my
neck the other one was taking shots at
my ribs he bruised my ribs for like
three months
they spit my lip busted my I messed up
all my neck he stepped on my neck so
hard that he actually pushed my Adam's
apple so far back that I might much
throat was hurting for like about three
months
well they end up figuring out who I am I
am even my real name to take me to the
station now they're telling me all my
charges down you can charge me most of
them is [ __ ] couple of immunity
you know industr evidence they got there
chatting other people were telling it
after snitches very reliable informants
so I'm debating you know how much time
I'm gonna take so at that time I think
the county jail and it is time the
county jail still active as hell
still got being homies on the line still
gotta [ __ ] running everywhere I don't
mean that bad by that we should like one
sec she was running everywhere you know
counties because just a strict jungle
it's just out of hand so I get there and
every time I'm there you are I'm having
a ball having fun I'm making Puno I'm
buying dope you know everywhere I go I
gotta cheer I get the keys to right
there so I wanna charge her everything
so everything that comes in and out has
to pass my hands every you know every
tight every area money order that people
buy the way it comes passes my hands I
log it in foot my long way and
city where we gots to go well I'm in
there fighting my case you know I'm
thinking by another chunk you'd be 35
your life that's where they're at 35
your life you don't want to go down they
don't want to move I'm trying to telling
me I'll take 20 years right now 20 years
I even went to 25 I come I'll take 25
years no nope
I mean you nothing so we wait we
postpone trial we post one trial what
happens maybe about two weeks before two
days before we pick jury the high
patrolman that was that scene crime and
everything and if you entering an
accident on the freeway on 6:05 catching
the 90 some lady ran and hit him her son
was fighting he's no longer with us so
went to court his house right there in
court though I'm sorry I did the rest
night passed away pretty steep so he's
all the good news is whatever he said in
the beginning can't use anything after
cos he's long just footing role in the
police report and police report was all
[ __ ] up now I wanted to find a
discrepancy in my case on where can I
beat my kidnaps because my murders all
right I already dropped them up they got
me on to thousands of kidnap and I'm
thinking damn where's the discrepancy in
my case something where I can fight this
know me hold I'm going through my
transcript and they're saying that I'm
being arrested and tried for two counts
of kidnap but if you remember in the
beginning the story I explained
something and I said when I supposedly
put the gun to the base of her skull
I told her turn that she turned right I
told her keep going she stopped I told
her stop she kept going so when you
really look and I was never ever in
power of her I never ready took command
and made her do things she didn't want
to do everything I told her she did the
exact opposite now mind you would
supposed to be a 12 inch guns
her skull she wasn't obeying my commands
so at that point I said wait a minute
how are they gonna be Charlie trying to
convict me of a kidnap when I never ever
had actual control of this person that
drops it to attempt to kidnap maybe even
false imprisonment because I never was
in command I never actually at one time
if I would have told her to him right
and she would have turned right more
than I was in command I had control but
due to the fact that she did not obey my
commands I was never ever really in
charge so I went in court an X on my
lawyer which I had a pay lawyer he
charged me $12,000 that's what he
charged me to represent me that was just
to go in there and I get a man's pretty
good out of Norwalk but he wasn't too
bright up here because I seen what he
didn't see then when I brought to his
attention he kind of got upset because
he didn't see it but I told him all I
got the idea from you when you were
telling me the other day about you
explained to me what about the case and
I drew it off of what you were telling
me and I came up with hey I was never a
control soul how's he gonna give me four
kidnaps I never couldn't have anybody
because the fact that I totally never
had control so we go in court we present
that and all of a sudden they're talking
about 15 years and I'm taking away his
teen years I just got him down from 35
to 15 years
[ __ ] I'll take it
I said I'll take it I was 17 years old I
figured I'll get out when I'm 30 by that
time you know I mean [ __ ] it to be the
older Amina I won't be so radical with
my beliefs you know the way I believed I
would be so devious so cunning so so so
so mean at times you know so awful very
terrible you know I was very very sick
individual
and I figured I went to prison I get a
little bit schooling I mean I get some
education I'll get some
I'll find some new ways to commit some
crimes you know because that's a jail if
you want to know how to do something you
just go to jail on asking so we're
talking exactly step by step how to do
this so I end up taking the 15 we get to
court leading six years for what getting
that sick search for another kidnap
anyone gave me your to be for the guy
what God there is no that they never
found good if you remember beginning I
said that climbing for treat I broke a
branch and I hit the gun by the truth
you're gonna set there for all the time
I want to prison oh I was a prison for
six years
I set for six years in prison when I got
out I went back and got my gun I went
back and got my gun now the reason I got
my guns because you know when I got out
this time I was it this time I was
leaving the family life you know mean I
had a job a nice car a nice apartment
you know very beautiful wife beautiful
daughter and the hood kept calling they
kept pulling me well all my brothers all
my cousins therefore my and there's one
of my cousins that he's like a brother
to me so I get a phone call to house my
wife answers here they want you boom I
pick it up it's my little bro he's like
hey we need to meet we need to meet I'm
like wait a minute
you need some heat what do you mean I've
been gone away for six years you guys
been out here you guys don't have no
heat you guys want my [ __ ] no you ain't
getting my [ __ ] so calling they're
calling Fame I had calls what the hell
is going on here
these guys are digging up the whole
backyard you need to tell them where
it's at the guys telling what [ __ ] that
yeah funny
just going so much I get out my over
legs home look man I'm gonna tell you
exactly where it's at
do you know that I told him exactly
where was that they dug up the whole
[ __ ] backyard we never touched that
one spot I told him what be going was
that I can actually told him it was
everywhere else and they wouldn't talk
on that one spot cuz they had to call me
to go over there so I go when they get
to my grandma's backyard
they're all back there sweaty all dirty
and I look at the yard and there must
have been at least 15 to 20 holes big
my grandfather's jar very nice there's
holes everywhere I'm like oh my God he's
[ __ ] dudes man
I [ __ ] gave him throw throw throw map
how to fight it you know I told come
here stupid mutt so I dig him up I
pulled him out I must have like seven
guns in there they've been sitting in
there you know so I pull out field might
give one small call once my little
brother wants my cousin and I'm good
that's dozer for here you walk around
here and you so you don't go to another
hoodie music no that's not what these
before these are for strictly for our
hood it's when people come in we got him
having to get him back out well I gave
one of my brother one of my uncle you
know my uncle is in the middle of my
hood my uncle I go to his house one day
and ask me where's the gun that I gave
you oh I got it okay well I need it
let's see it do you know this guy
winning got a [ __ ] power drill and he
[ __ ] started on drilling screws from
the wall in the garage and I was like
what are you doing he said I'm getting
the gun wait you're kidding you got them
you've got the gurney locked behind a
wall bolted in how are you supposed to
get to this well you have to handle
business or they come then I have just
put time out and yet you take all these
screws get this out and then I'm have it
no so I am taking it back from him and
I'm thinking damn I cannot drive from my
hood to my house with a gun you know
what there Stryker what am I gonna do so
I'm looking at my truck I'm looking at
my truck boom I see my big fear I got a
1500 meter
big two big old 15 mega big speakers and
they're in a box so what I do is I take
the box apart
I get the gun and I tape the gun to the
inside of the box and I put the
speaker's back on put your speaker bag
and I Drive home I never even took it
out of the box I left it in the box I'm
driving over I got pulled over several
times they searched everything never
that gun came in handy when I needed it
was very nice but what happens is I end
up getting went back to the time I had
been giving me 12 years digging man 12
and when I get the time you are lungs
they're talking about you're gonna do
every last day of it you need to do all
12 years well kind of said you know I
mean you know that's my first one I can
sit and put in much work but uh one time
I'm sitting up there and on each max in
the county jail and I see these two
individuals are getting escorted and a
few more images are coming and then
three more calm and excited I to me I
grab the car get take your bridges put
it away you know because you got a who a
hot ass guy
there's you cannot walk around without
expanding jail you get cotton county
over the high tax cut you get your ass
smashed and you owe 200 are fine no you
know you caught one of those go $200 by
three days if you can't handle those
$300 and doubles to $600 then goes to 12
on it are good I don't understand when
to keep doing that because if the fool
can't pay the first 200 let me see
thinking advanced 600 bones you can pay
1200 you're charging me more money when
you can't even pay the initial few
hundred you know and that's the way they
do it you know so I get the kite and I
hope it I take you back to where I'm at
where I'm house that I open it up and
unless it's orders from headquarters
how to handle some business you know me
and where I'm going wherever I end up
they're letting me know hey no one's
there get it grabbed sew it up get back
at us and that's you know a yard so this
is my first term I really don't want to
get him over a lot of [ __ ] but I mean
just because of where I'm from and
because one more aid to a lot of
[ __ ] just follows me it just
surrounds me I mean those dudes that
know who my uncle ways or who my cousin
is and they come and ask me for advice
and want me to give them their
to do this and I'm like no I'm not gonna
give you information to do [ __ ] because
when it comes down to it you're gonna
put my [ __ ] in there and I'm not
gonna answer for [ __ ] you know I
could speak of values about certain
things here I was talking about but
always keep names and [ __ ] out to
protect the innocent what am I here to
tell anybody I'm not here to give a
vital information I'm just expressing
things that I have been through things
I've been through life phases I have
been where I've gone and what hits me up
in my head and tells me the worst place
I've ever been and I've been to 15
different prisons I'm into the harmony
show I've been everywhere but the worst
place I've ever been was the awakening
game and I've been a lot of places I've
been in a lot of situations but when I
hit the allocating going I go for the
first time I remember exactly what
happened we got caught for a right to
consult downstairs they [ __ ] fill out
paperwork and then they line us up and
they took us to the tier were gonna be
on now as we're walking I'm in the front
because I was the first one they wanted
to interview because of my hood and we
were active again and they wanted to put
me in a jihad so all the first one he
talked to you so I'm in the front of the
line as we cut through what they call
the module we could for the module were
going to able row it solved the role and
the last on the end on the bottom do you
know that when we made that laugh and
then we made that little right to get in
front of the tears at the door then when
I made that next and I made that right
when I stepped up to that door
I felt I don't know if it was because
she air or something but I felt
something hit my chest so hard that I
hit the two dudes behind me and they
dude behind me dude behind the guy I was
behind said what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
was that I didn't know what it was
I still today don't know it was all I
can do is give it just a naming and try
to explain the best I can on what it was
me I think we'll straight death
that's right thing because
when I got in that when I got an edge
here and do what I do and everybody else
do they have to do I knew like that I
knew right after that that that's what
that really was
and like I said I've been a lot of cases
I would do a lot of prisons you know
right alleys all these [ __ ] spots but
never ever have I felt such tension such
anger since hey hostility in one place
when that thing hit me in my chest
it didn't feel cold it didn't feel hot
it just felt clean nasty a feeling
inside my body well I understand after I
figured out I knew it was death that I
felt but I'm on she hit me so hard it
knocked me in two individuals I never
ever liked it behind me I never ever
felt nothing like that but I knew once I
got on that chair
once I got on that chair five minutes
later I was standing somebody five
minutes later I was stabbing somebody
and I don't even been on that chair for
five minutes I didn't even get a chance
for my [ __ ] guy because of the fact that
when you get there they put your own one
sound and you're all packed in there
with about seven dudes and they all got
big-ass knives on now what they're doing
is they get your name your booking over
and they send it to the streets on the
streets they call the county get all the
information give it back to the person
that we call you in and I only
information comes back but it mind you
during this time that information is
going back and forth you can't put your
[ __ ] down you can't sit on over you read
you got to stand there and wait all that
time for that to come back due to super
fact that if one comes back wrong he's
getting handled on the spot you know I'm
saying in you know you're sitting there
and you're waiting and Dean's are like
vultures they're like piranhas
circling the tank you know they're
hoping that somebody shits gonna come
back dirty I know why she's in because
so effective when they're about to run
my [ __ ] not already handing me the phone
so I got on the floor
talk to you so I put my [ __ ] down you
know I mean I I was I was already to the
point where I already known people are
putting work out you did my thing so
they don't have to run my name in black
and white
I'm just telling tell whoever you're on
the phone would tell them you know I
mean I'm pretty sure they know who I am
and that's what happened yeah they told
somebody that I was there and they say
hey you wanna talk to you yeah here we
go here we go you got - got any a you do
this do that do this and I was like all
right cool so about 20 minutes later
they tell me that somebody has to get
handled something that I mean somebody
has to get stabbed so they tell me you
know can you do this and have it go
unlock then you know pass this but yeah
first day I'm there I'm already on the
chair they cured my name the other dudes
excuse me are still in that room waiting
for the name you get clear sometimes it
takes hours she's been taking hours
let's have it took a whole day the kids
didn't sleep who they were waiting on
information you come back cuz you're not
allowed to put your [ __ ] down and relax
because we don't know who you are what
you're busted for what waiting for her
to come back from the streets like I
said it if it comes back all bad your
tools money they're gonna kill you on
that chair they're gonna do what they
have to do with you and they're gonna
take as much time as they need because
it simple fact that that's all we have
is time in their tiny soul
time was so good but yet time so evil
you know because there was a guy where I
was at in that gang watching and dude
used to come for situations that happen
out there with him on the line because
we're slammed down okay our deed would
get there and I picked this up along the
way I watched how this guy did what he
did was the didn't get there and he has
to yell on I hear what he wants to talk
to him about he's like hey we'll call
his dude Jojo he's like hey Jojo can you
tell me
on paper what happened out there with
you so judging is paper and settlement
pattern paper he writes it all down dude
gets it reads it lets me read it and
then folds it up and puts it away so
George is like oh so you know I got that
touchdown no we're buying the guy George
awaits the whole week never says nothing
about it the next week exactly a week
later he's like hey George oh yeah hey
uh remember what she walked down the
other day and he hits the pad I had to
get rid of it ball chain you write it
down again yeah sweetie wrote it down
again so we waited I mind you we're in
the back we're not going anywhere
everybody stuck right there so he's you
know patient about a month later he said
he had it quiet on the chair I need to
talk to somebody
so everybody is quiet and cheer you
can't make no noise you make a noise you
meet you [ __ ] ass smash which he
misses - what's going on all you want
so he calls Joe Joe Hey Joe Joe yeah
what's up and go ahead and tell me in
your own words what happened out there
tells me Johnny we're in the same salad
he wants me to get where he's at what he
does is he puts the two papers down side
by side
go on Joe Joe wrote in the beginning and
in the middle now we're gonna hear Joe
Joe's story and he tells me
wait up Joe Joe this is a Johnny keep
this paper that paper listen to his
story if anything in his story it's not
what's right here on paper the line and
I refill he's lying so here we go Joe
just starts talking about his story and
his story it's not adding up with what
he wrote down so what the dude did was
he's time as his friend what he did was
he had Joe Joe write it down once
write it down again and now he has him
telling it so he's gonna tell a lie the
story is gonna change because its allies
making it up as he goes along it's not
actual fact actual fact is gonna be this
paper in this paper and his story are
gonna be identical because it actually
took place now this is what I picked up
and I used it along the way when I was
in situations and I wanted to know what
happened to this dude on the yard says
you got to go to the state I'd use that
scenario and and it was something that I
learned in jail and it was so good that
you know what made the guys think of
something like that I mean you got a lot
of time in jail and you think about a
lot of [ __ ] but who would actually think
okay I got this dude back here every
four months I'm gonna tell him to tell
me his story three times and if it
changes its his ass and Jojo was not
there no longer woods it's like a day
later Jojo got me wet the [ __ ] out Jojo
you get the simple fact that his story
didn't add up you know it was totally
different than what he had written down
on paper so you know I share with you
because the fact that I learned so many
things in prison that I brought it with
me and I you like in a good way I don't
use him in a bad way the way he used to
with Jojo you know I mean because that
was what he was so patient and you know
we discussed about me being patient
I learned to be patient from these guys
in here that were patient men you know
because they're very patient and it's a
patient you know being patient that's a
virtue you know it's a good thing and it
is you know but there's certain things
that you can't be patient with you know
there's certain times when if you be
patient with this guy he didn't take
more advantage of you you know when he's
cannot gonna want to pay you what do you
always you or he's not gonna want to
give you whatever dope you have coming
you know and you know I I admired prison
in a way where prison made me even very
very humble it humbled me in a fashion
we're not saying that wasn't having
business no always kind of business
that's not gonna stop what I mean while
hallways I learned things in here and
things in there in certain scenarios
where in other words I wouldn't even
think of that idea I wouldn't even
fathom the thought of making a man you
know Toy Story 4 times they catch him in
a lie you know it's so devious in there
and he plays so many my knees in there
that you know I see guys just lying
lying lying you know
they got another thing in there say I go
in there and I take something that
belongs to me it's for me well you know
I have to give a third of that give it
away just someone I don't even know I
don't mind if the cause is right but I
don't like where yeah it's going
upstairs what time he gets upstairs
they've been touched like 15 times so
what I sent up there is not actually
getting up there I might have sent five
grams and they only get a half but if
you touches so many hands as it goes
along because it has to reach its
destination you know but at the same
time you got you're dealing with don't
fees these connivers you know everything
you could think of buns you know and so
many people are touching that there you
got a room where you're at you're at
words the close focus correct you know
commit all kinds of crimes you know and
if you're gonna send something through
the ground
you know it's liable to get touched
there's dudes that will take that gamble
and touch something but little did you
know you know these things are wrapped
in a certain way where it's wrapped with
a green balloon it came for the streets
for the green balloon any five green
balloon inside chair and rewrap it so if
they get that issue and they open that
issue and that green balloon breaks it's
their ass cuz you can't retie it it's
tight so tight with a little ass not if
you want to eat in it you have to
actually break that and if that green
balloon is broken somebody touches that
issue you know so that was something
outside aren't you know they they do so
many things in jail where they do it to
a point where they know if something's
been touched or somebody's been
tampering with [ __ ] you
I've seen I've seen a Bible a Bible that
every third page had nothing but 50 are
scenes of heroin inside the Bible
now this Bible just got handed from the
priests tsunami he had in the Bible with
that much know in every third page it
would iron it so thin that they would
actually put it 10 of them in there and
iron iron shut through the pages
together so when they got the book and
they went cuz they're just gonna run
their finger along it see if anything
would fall out nothing's gonna fall out
because everything is sewed in the pages
but the best one I ever seen was I do
got a package with some basic Cheetos he
tells me a Johnnie o'clock we opened the
bag of Cheetos He pours them all on top
of a piece of plastic in his bed and he
shows well do you know that they put
little yellow straws about that big back
then we'd owe dr. shields another bag of
Cheetos putting them in a poll crunch
them all up put a little bit of water
then they got the strong pack your dope
burn both the ends and then got the
cheeto and just put the cheeto together
remember a chill doesn't have any shape
to it they're different size in it they
got the cheetah and they put all the
stuff back on each straw so there was 30
shawls inside each bag there was four
bags each bag contained 30 straws inside
but you couldn't see the straw since you
got the cheetah and you actually either
bid it or took it apart but that was the
best thing when they do put the chilies
down and he grabbed me went back and
then he went up and he showed me the
strong I was like heroin glass weed but
the way they did was they made the dough
strong and they just put the cheeto back
together through her back in the bag
sealed the bag bag shook the bag a
little and saying it's on its way
because anything on the ground doesn't
get x-ray
in the air you know if you say you're
sending something you don't want to get
to have her with you standing on the
ground just two months ago we received
the box in the mail not addressed to us
but it was just in the mailbox so we got
it i sat it on the refrigerator didn't
touch it for all week finally I was like
what the [ __ ] is in this box
do you know in that box you know was in
there two ounces of glass and an ounce
of heroin and found it in the mail found
the mail just found the box on top of me
I walked so was just sitting there on
that farm take this box [ __ ] you can
sit there for three days why he was
sitting for three days outside outside
I grabbed me to go I put it up but I
didn't think twice of it but when I
opened it that was it that wolf that's
what was in there announcer Ellen and
she wants a glass don't know who is
going to because I know it had a fake
name but it just happened to come to our
mailbox is that so I grabbed me you know
so boys he net was like you know being
in jail you you you pick up so many
traits you know a a lighter that just
has a flip that just flicks no little
flame to it it's just as good as a
lighter that works you know how you do
is get some toilet paper get it twist it
up leave a little bit of it sticking out
there's some uh link from your sock put
it on top of that so paper get the
lighter turn it upside down scrape it to
a little flip falls on that link and
then you just flick it away
it ignites you know that's just a way to
get fire you know another one is there's
a light socket get two pieces of leg you
need three physically you have two
pieces of land and you stick them inside
the socket each socket then you get
another piece of leg hit a troller paper
fold it over twist the legs with a leg
sticking out you got to troll the paper
you chap it and it explodes with another
please talk with you having a sight and
explodes it it's [ __ ] and it likes
this whole river and you ever like no I
would before I would not stick anything
inside and out it but because we're in a
place where we
you need the light I have to stick the
lid inside the [ __ ] LD nine times out
of ten I'm the wild to work you know
they're cheer cuz I want to know what's
going on in my house so I'm the one
working on the chair you know I've
popped that like I pop that sucker so
many times where I took the power and
half of the building one time and that
[ __ ] must have blew up and lathes got
shot like bullets Jeep they hit the
walls like it just blew up too big I
went to hit it it blew up and fire came
out and he just blew those legs and his
chocolate is everywhere probable he only
bumps him here you learn so many things
in jail how to do things how to make
[ __ ] you know and then so many dudes
aren't telling you you know how to cook
dog you know how to sound or what not to
do the next time you get out you know
they run you down so much [ __ ] that I
think then you get out more of a devious
person you get out with more vital
information you know what I mean you it
makes you it made me a very cautious
individual you know I'm very cautious
with what I do you know i I've I've did
so many things in jail and got away with
them
- I've been to places where dudes are
like how the [ __ ] ain't you back here
yet with us I just planned my [ __ ] out
you know I I go plan a plan B and Plan C
you know if you're gonna stab would do
it on the yard you know you you have to
have some Getaway Plan you know because
you're on a yard you have to have an
extra set of clothes you know you you
have to think of it so good to get away
with it my only thing was to get away
get away with it
I've been things and got away with it
because I just didn't jump the gun
I'm not that individual that wants to go
burn all kinds of points and stab a dude
right under the gun Tower no I rather be
the guy jogging around the track and the
third lap run by it stick it in his neck
and just keep running and then running
to handball court and take those clothes
off plus the Fiat and start playing
handball but tiny bit the buzzer and get
this dude I'm already done sweating
paint hammer
getting people see me Campbell and I did
it within the nick of time was in the
nick of time I hit him on the [ __ ] and
stepped out of my clothes Brian some
other clothes and got away with it I got
it with so much [ __ ] but I'm saying you
know it sure because gel makes you a
whole different type of man hold you can
type of individual you see it all there
you hear every lie you see every story
happen over and over and over and over
again and people think oh man that's
Johnny he goes what time is know johnny
has just seen the same scenario that
you're in right now happened with just
different individuals with the same
thing happened now the way I'm gonna do
it is okay now I wanna handle the
situation
okay I can do it this way but damn last
time you did it that way at end of all
bad or I can do it this way the way I've
seen it in all these times and
everything just came out good so they've
come with a problem I'll give them the
answer then they'll go bad let's say how
did you know because I seen the same
scenario happen over and over and over
again for just different individuals
just different men the only thing
different is every man acts reaction is
different you know you got dudes that
you can pump up and they'll go handle
business but as soon as they're done
having business they deflate and become
that weak individual that they were in
the beginning you just pump them up and
gave them a little bit of you know yeah
I could do it and when after they do it
they're no good here anymore they're
what you call expandable you become
expandable you become yeah it's
expensive become expendable you know you
we don't need you we just get rid of you
because there's like 50 more
[ __ ] that Oh being a miner yeah
because you know us mean Southsiders we
never run short in jail if they move 50
rolls off the yard 50 more back on so
you know it doesn't really matter you
know yeah I want to share that with you
today about things I learned in jail you
know
yoanne and and i share them with you to
the fact that these things I learned in
they take me through life now I use them
out here but I usually mainly in a
positive manner some I still gotta use
negative because there are some do there
and that need to throw ass whuppin you
let me mark I got you don't like any
time brother you know
you